bonsoir nous sommes le 8 novembre
nouvelle édition du 7 8 votre rendez
vous quotidien avec l information dans
le département des yvelines avant de
découvrir le sommaire en images
accueille sur ce plateau
la michel schaffner bonsoir je vous êtes
responsable de la vie syndicale à la cgt
des yvelines on va parler des élections
professionnelles avec vous pour la
première fois les salariés des tpe les
très petites entreprises qui comptent
moins de 11 salariés sont concernés ils
sont appelés à voter par correspondance
ou par internet on va en parler avec
vous bonsoir également en lice avec vous
également pour la rédaction de tv film
revient sur l'économie c est toutes les
semaines tous les jeudis sur ted et fils
oui tout à fait et ce soir il sera
question de l'auto entreprenariat un
statut qui fête ses quatre ans cette
année et un forum spécialement un dédiée
aux auto entrepreneurs de plaisir était
organisée donc dans cette ville pour
mettre un petit peu en avance ce statut
et puis nous reviendrons aussi sur deux
entreprises du territoire qui sont en
plein développement avec de nouveaux
invités sur ce plateau également la
chronique de l'écho comme tous les
jeudis dans une vingtaine de minutes aux
alentours 18h20 si vous nous suivez en
direct la suite c'est le sommaire en
images les principaux sujets que vous
allez découvrir au cours de cette
édition poursuite de la mobilisation
chez alcatel à vélizy les syndicats
refusent la fermeture du site yvelinois
et envisage des actions coup de poing
des entreprises qui débouche
et puis d'autres qui peine à recruter
c'est le cas de softeam à guyancourt
la société est spécialisée dans le
conseil en informatique compte 700
collaborateurs dans l'hexagone les
recherches une cinquantaine de salariés
2 préférence résidant dans
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise à la
proximité habitat travail une
préoccupation de ces chefs d'entreprise
il a 17 ans et ce jeune le fontenaisien
et passionné d'histoire à quelques jours
du 11 novembre date anniversaire de
l'armistice de 14-18 à léon dubois
propose une exposition sur la première
guerre mondiale
il sera aussi sur ce plateau et puis un
opéra pour les enfants en plein de
tendresse en ce moment au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines momo composé
par pascal dusapin et mise en scène par
andré ville ça pour débuté voici donc
quelques images du site d'alcatel lucent
à vélizy les salariés sont toujours
mobilisés suite à l'annoncé de la
suppression de plus de 1400 postes en
france
la direction prévoit également la
fermeture de ce site historique des
yvelines l'activité devrait être
transféré à nausées dans l'essonne avant
le mois de septembre 2013 et ce matin
syndicats et salariés ont organisé le
blocage d'un bâtiment une troisième
action coup-de-poing afin de faire plier
la direction on va écouter à ce sujet
didier ringot délégué syndical et
délégué du personnel de la cgt c'était
très qu' on est capable aussi de
perturber un peu le travail et que le
plan de licenciements et la fermeture de
vélizy ça se passera pas en douceur à 10
heures on avait une assemblée générale
de ses salariés on a eu 600 personnes
quand même qu'ils sont venus à cette
assemblée générale
pour un effectif russie qui est de norme
allemande autour de 2100 mais a priori
quand même moins de salariés présents
avec le télétravail et ses 600 personnes
c'est pas mal assez content de la
mobilisation pour l'instant l'objectif
de l'assemblée générale c'était de
discuter afin de présenter aux collègues
les actions qui sont prévues
on a ce qu'on est prévu c'est
une manifestation eux
jusqu'à la mairie de vélizy pour
pour parler aussi de la fermeture du
site parce que les licenciements
c'est grave la fermeture du site c'est
un des moyens qu'utilise la direction
pour pousser les gens à
assad à démissionner pour pour réaliser
son plan de licenciement donc non combat
à la fois le les licenciements et la
fermeture du site
on a aussi en prévision une
manifestation au siège social ou de
suffren à paris
probablement une manifestation enfin à
l'occasion du cce fin novembre
commencera à discuter effectivement des
oeufs
des vraies mesures d'une mise en oeuvre
pour le plan de licenciement et
bon là on continue d'essayer de
mobiliser et de monter en puissance sur
cette mobilisation
la question de la grève a été évoquée
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on finira pas en
arriver là si sa direction ne recule pas